hello I'm working packing today I'm
gonna show you one of my favorites a
tomato risotto with sauteed shrimp and
fresh peas when you make a risotto at
home always stay next to it don't leave
and go and watch TV or anything like
that or play with the kids if not the
rice will burn now it's very important
that you don't add all the liquid at
once even if you have the exact
measurement you wanna steal it so that
way the risotto really nice and creamy
we're gonna finish the risotto with a
little bit of butter and some Parmesan
cheese normally when I make a risotto
with seafood I don't add a lot of
parmesan to it or no Parmesan cheese and
the fish sometimes don't mix but I make
the risotto and then I cook the shrimp
seperated that way parmesan in the
risotto works well now we are ready to
saute our strength when I fart apply the
shrimp I leave the tail here as you can
see and then you cut the shrimp in half
so it's really simple so that way it's
easier for presentation and faster to
cook I think my kids really love to cook
and Byron started to cook risotto
probably when he was in high school but
Oliver my son who is 12 now he started
to cook with me in the morning breakfast
really early and then for dinner when we
make anything which is not too
complicated like risotto he's always
next to it steering he burned himself a
few times cut himself a few thumb
I could eat risotto every day it's tasty
it has great texture and most of all to
me the creaminess of the risotto is so
amazing it smells amazing I can't wait
to taste it
we're the delicious shrimp method mmm oh
yes
[Music]
you
[Music]